Zootopia fans check this out we found
some totally bizarre mistakes in the
film that most people missed
watch until the end to find out the
biggest oops moment in the film you'll
be shocked you missed it the first time
around
quick change while cooking carrots in
the scene where judy goes home to her
apartment after an awful day at work we
noticed a wardrobe mistake judy goes to
the microwave to heat up a container of
carrots for one side note that might be
the saddest packaged food item we've
ever seen anyway before she heats up the
carrots she's wearing her meter maid
uniform then while she watches the
carrot package cook in the microwave
she's wearing a pink shirt cut her
opening the cooked carrot package and
she's back in her meter maid uniform
either she did the fastest wardrobe
change ever or the animators gooped
chief BOGO please five minutes of your
time please mrs. Otterton Spurs in the
scene where Emmitt Otterton 's wife is
holding up a picture of her missing
husband Emmitt mrs. Otterton Spurs can
be seen hanging on her left arm here's a
cutaway to Judi looking at mrs. Otterton
with concern when we cut back we see a
close-up of the uttered end family photo
but something else besides Emmitt
Otterton has gone missing look closely
there's no purse hanging from mrs.
Otterton arm in the close-up then after
another shot of judy there's a wide shot
of mrs. Otterton and her purse is back
on her arm a real page-turner
in the scene where judy is catching Nick
for tax evasion I made 200 bucks a day
fluff 365 days a year since I was 12
something interesting happens to the
pages in Judy's folder
Judy is totaling up Nick's income for
the year now she jot down notes with her
handy carrot pen flash recorder she
turns a page in the folder but when we
see the folder from the other angle the
page has been turned back and all the
mattes she scribbled out before it is
missing from the page it's just a bunch
of zeros
did you just boot my stroller Nichols
while you're under arrest where did that
thing come from
we know rabbits are quick but Judy's got
some lightning speed boots skills
disappearing reappearing walkie-talkie
of course when you're animating a
fast-paced action sequence it's only
natural that some details get overlooked
for instance in the part of the film
where Nick and Judy are running from the
savage mr. Montes Judy loses her
walkie-talkie it takes a long fall down
to the forest floor beneath her but a
short while later when chief BOGO and
the other officers find Judy her
walkie-talkie has magically reappeared
not to mention it doesn't have a scratch
on it
so either the walkie-talkie grew wings
cleaned itself up and flew back on to
Judy's belt or the animators had a
little oops moment magic doughnuts this
scenes between Judy Hopps and clawhauser
are adorable and funny and they also
contain a mistake you might have missed
there's a part where Judy is telling
clawhauser that it's not okay for him to
refer to bunnies as cute then he talks
about how he's stereotyped as a flabby
doughnut loving cob while he's talking
we don't see anything in his collar or
near his neck right in your neck
the further you went you little Dickens
oh we see a doughnut it wasn't there
before but then suddenly it appeared hmm
it must be one of those magic doughnuts
time-jump many viewers have pointed out
this next mistake from Zootopia you know
how sometimes a short phone call with
your parents can feel way longer than it
actually is
well this little whoopsy moment
accidentally and perfectly demonstrates
that feeling it happens in the scene
where Judy is talking to her parents on
the phone after her first day at her new
job if you look at the time on her phone
its 8:40 p.m. then just a second later
when she's putting her phone down we see
that the phone says 944 p.m. so Judy's
phone either has the ability to time
travel or the animators made a slight
error weasel or stoked
remember this slippery criminal from the
film who goes by the name duke weaselton
well some fans
questioning if duke is a weasel at all
people have pointed out that he looks
more like a stoat than a weasel after
checking out some Stoke footage on
National Geographic we're gonna have to
side with the fans on this one Duke has
a long tail with a black tip this is
characteristic of a stoat not a weasel
weasels have shorter tails without the
black tip fun fact don't trick rabbits
by hypnotizing them with a weird wiggle
dance so they can get close enough to
snatch them for lunch
lights Lookout duty bags with legs
speaking of duke weaselton fans think
they found a mistake in one of his
scenes it happens during the scene where
judy is pursuing Duke for stealing a
duffel bag full of flower bulbs Duke
falls next to the donut shop and his bag
falls on the street by the shop but then
in the next shot the bag has moved
farther away so did the bag grow legs
and walk away upon further review it
doesn't look like the bag moved but
without an accurate measurement or being
in the animation room with the animators
there is no real way to know for sure
however this next mistake is undeniable
moving lock don't you hate it when the
locks on your door magically change
places on you oh right that's not a
thing that happens in real life but in
the animation world anything is possible
like when Judy first moves into her new
apartment take a look at the deadbolt
lock it's super close to the doorknob
but in a later scene the deadbolt has
moved further up on the door away from
the doorknob we'd like to point out that
we only notice this one because we're
huge fans of the movie predator or prey
the website the gamer com made a pretty
astute observation they pointed out that
Zootopia makes the general assumption
that all animal species that are
categorized as prey are seen as timid in
meat but that's not totally accurate
rabbits deer rhinos and hippos all fall
in the prey category because they're all
herbivores but the film shows the Rhinos
and hippos as tough cops while depicting
Judy as a timid rabbit in the wild they
would all be considered prey of course a
vegetarian Rhino could still take out a
predator in a stampede while a bunny
can't do much but run and hide
still it's an interesting point of view
did we miss any big mistakes in Disney's
Zootopia
if so tell us in the comments and that's
a wrap
give this video a big thumbs up if you
love Zootopia be sure to subscribe to
our channel to be the first to catch our
latest videos thanks for watching the
things well see you soon
[Music]